Aggregation in MongoDB uses a pipeline. At the
far left is your collection, so for example tweets.
The collection is fed into the first stage
and the first stage processes the documents in some
way, and passes the results onto the next
stage. Each stage does this type of work, processes
the documents it receives as inputs, and produces
output documents that are passed to the next stage.
Now in the example that we looked at in the
previous lesson, the stages included were a group stage and
a sort stage. It's the group stage that actually does
the aggregation. Let's take a look at a pipeline specific to
that example. Okay, we'll zoom into this, but this is
a representation of the aggregation pipeline that we saw in
our previous example. Again, that example looks like this. So,
here is our aggregate query. Okay. So, here in this column,
we're representing the collection being fed into that first group
stage. And then, what the group stage then passes onto
the sort stage. And then, this is the output of
the group stage and then finally, the output of the sort
stage. Let's take a look at each of these in
just a little bit more detail. Okay, so here's our collection.
And you can see that I've represented several documents within
the collection, and in fact, multiple documents for some of the
Twitter users, okay. This collection will be fed
into the group stage. So what does group do?
Well, group is going to find the screen
name field for the user sub document in each
one of our tweets. And it's going to
aggregate together, it's going to accumulate all of those
tweets and then count them. So, here we
can see that for this Twitter user, we get
a count of eight tweets. Because that's how many
were found in the entire collection of tweets. So,
the group stage produces documents that look like, this
from documents that have the shape of those in
the collection itself, in the tweets collection itself. So
the sort stage then, takes this type of document
as input and produces this as output. Remember, sort
is sorting into reverse order. So, it's producing documents
that look exactly the same as these, simply sorted,
so that the ones that have the highest count
are at the top. So one thing that it's
very important to bear in mind, when you're thinking about
the aggregation framework in MongoDB, is that. Depending on
which operator is used in a given stage. That
stage may be reshaping the data, sometimes quite significantly.
The collection of tweets contains dozens of fields. What we've
done here, what our group stage does, as it
creates documents that look very different from these to
do its job. So the whole idea with the
aggregation pipeline, is that you use aggregation operators, to construct
stages that will in a series of steps, process
your data in such a way that it produces
the results you need. Sometimes a single stage is
enough, other times you need several stages. And the individual
operators that are used in a given stage are
entirely dependent on your application. Exactly what type of processing
you want to do. You're not whetted to using group
in the first stage or sort in the last stage.